You hear their footsteps coming down
the halls. Or are those your own?
Can you even tell the difference? You can tell
they’re getting closer and you can feel the hate,
the rage. You turn, shaking, and finally
see them standing right in front of you.
But in that moment, you might as
well be looking into a mirror.
And who knows? Perhaps you are. You just don’t
seem to remember having so many reflections...
Have you ever heard the saying “You
are your own worst enemy?” Of course,
it isn’t usually meant literally. But what if
it was? What if you had to fight a monster…that
was you? All of your flaws are reflected
back at you. Your strengths, your weaknesses,
your deepest fears, with no way to escape
except a battle to the death. Either way,
you’re not making it out alive. It’s just a
matter of which version of you survives. But
this isn’t a thought experiment. No, according to
the findings of the SCP Foundation, it’s very much
a reality. There is a place where this nightmare
comes to life, and it is known as SCP-1919.
SCP-1919 is a hotel and converted
mansion, built in the early 20th century.
From the outside, it looks pretty much
like it did when it was first built,
and it almost looks like a
comfortable place to stay…
if you ignore the eastern side of the building
that has sunk partially into the ground.
The inside, however, is a different story, where
it’s clear the ravages of time have taken their
toll. The floorboards and ceilings are rotting,
collapsing in on themselves, and the rooms are
filled with debris. It’s deadly enough to explore
the hotel for these reasons alone, but this is
only the beginning of the danger for a person
inside. In order to determine just how dangerous
it is for either one person or group to enter the
structure, the SCP Foundation planned a series of
research expeditions into the abandoned building,
led by Foundation scientist Dr. Limkiewicz.
The first expedition seemed relatively
normal, at least it did at the start.
A 39-year-old Caucasian D-Class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a camera
and a communications system, guided remotely by
Dr. Limkiewicz, or Dr. L, and another operative,
a former head of the MTF Tau-11 “Youth Hostiles”
who is referred to in this file only as T11.
When he arrived at the building, D7 was
unable to get inside through the front door
or windows. After several minutes of trial
and error, he was finally able to get in
through the western entrance. Dr. L picked
up a strange, high-pitched whistling noise
upon D7’s entrance into the building, but it
quickly faded away and was disregarded by T11.
D7 discovered a torn painting, a
portrait of a young woman with red hair.
Next to the portrait, shallow scratches
could be seen in the wall, the floor,
and parts of the ceiling. Suddenly, D7 ducked
into a hiding place, alarmed. He, and the other
two operatives listening to his audio feed could
hear heavy breathing… and it didn’t belong to D7.
Dr. L recommended that D7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity inside,
but T11 overruled, ordering him to disregard
that instruction and continue his investigation.
D7 was told to stay at a safe distance
from whatever was inside with him,
and attempt to capture it on video. D7 turned
off his flashlight in order to better hide, but
T11 commanded that he turn it back on. Whatever
was caught in its beam of light was difficult for
the camera to see, but it threw D7 into a panic
and he began to run in the opposite direction.
When prompted to explain what he
saw, D7 simply said: “It was me!”
D7 ran through the dark, panting with fear
and exertion. Unable to see where his feet
were landing, he tripped over something
and came crashing onto the ground,
dropping the video camera. This allowed the
observing officers to finally see what D7
was so frightened by, and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified.
A man, identical looking to D7,
approached from the end of the hallway,
making its way toward the real D7. It was
followed by another man who also resembled D7,
and another, all running toward the
original. They all looked exactly like him,
with a few notable differences. They
were dressed in the same uniform,
with the same build and the same features,
but each had something slightly off about him.
One was missing eyelids,
another had malformed hands,
and the third had its lips fused together
into a fleshy mass beneath its nose.
Dr. L moved to cut the camera feed, but T11
demanded that it be kept running. D7 couldn’t
be seen by the camera, but the microphone picked
up the sounds of flesh and cloth being torn, along
with pained, panicked screams as the duplicates
set upon him. After a moment, the screaming
stopped. Two hours later, the camera was broken,
and the expedition brought to a troubling end.
This was the Foundation’s first glimpse at the
creatures inside of SCP-1919, and it was not
pretty. It did, however, allow them to begin
understanding the nature of the building,
and what happens when a person goes inside.
It appears that when a human enters the hotel,
several humanoid creatures manifest throughout the
building. These creatures look like the subject,
and are equipped with the same clothing or items
that the subject brought inside with them. Though
they are nearly mirror images of the subject, they
are always slightly warped in a variety of ways.
These have included changes to limb and digit
length, joint mobility, sealed nostrils,
lengthened jaws hanging loose and limp, missing
eyelids, and lips that are fused together.
These creatures are highly aggressive
toward the structure of the building itself,
as well as to the subject that they resemble.
They do not, however, attack each other. They
appear to operate with a hive mind, exhibiting
swarm intelligence like that of an ant colony.
Once they have been spawned by
the entrance of a new person,
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed.
After the unfortunate end to the first expedition,
the Foundation prepped for a second trip inside.
This time, three men were sent in with
Dr. L’s guidance, known as D3, D4, and D9.
Video cameras were sewn into their clothes to
leave their hands free and to help avoid some
of the issues that came up during the first
expedition. This small team was sent in with
the orders to terminate the remaining copies of
D7, and further examine the hotel’s interior.
Upon opening the door to the building, they
were immediately attacked by one of D7’s copies,
which D9 was able to quickly dispatch
by firing his weapon at its head.
Next, after a great deal of reluctance,
the three men entered the building where
they spotted something unusual inside.
Dr. L was horrified when the camera feed
revealed seventeen discarded video
cameras spread across the floor.
They didn’t have much time to react
to this new discovery, however,
because two doubles, one mirroring
D7 and another mirroring D9,
emerged from the wall and began to attack.
Dr. L ordered the team to take shelter,
then called the team of guards outside of
the hotel’s perimeter. They were ordered
to begin an immediate full perimeter lockdown,
preventing the doubles from leaving the hotel.
D3, D4, and D9 attempted to make their
way to a safe corner of the building,
but found themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn. At this point, Dr. L began to hear
an unusual sound over the microphone feed, a
high-pitched whine like that of a dentist’s
drill. The operatives on the ground couldn’t hear
a thing, but on Dr. L’s end it was deafening.
As the team proceeded deeper into the hotel,
they became overcome with a strange feeling
of foreboding. Dr. L ordered them to turn
on their flashlights, but they refused and
begged Dr. L to keep quiet. When prompted
to explain, D9 said: “she can hear you.”
The operatives stopped responding,
but their camera feeds caught a faint,
glowing white light coming from
beneath a door. The door opened,
and the light flooded the camera, making
the images it captured hard to decipher.
Just a few frames of a quick-moving female
silhouette were captured before the cameras
cut to static. The bodies of D3, D4, and D9
were never recovered, nor were their cameras.
A third expedition was also sent into SCP-1919,
but very little is known about what occurred
during it. The video transcript is highly
classified and only those present for its events,
or approved to research SCP-1919, have access
to it. An update to the SCP-1919 file following
Expedition Three though, indicates that new
information was revealed about the hotel
during the excursion. According to the file
update, there is some kind of being at the
center of the location which is causing all of
the other creatures, the doubles, to appear.
The only information available about
this being is the use of the word
“her” in the official Foundation log about
SCP-1919. This seems to match up with the last
moments of the operatives in Expedition Two,
when they told Dr. L that “she can hear you”
and the few frames of a female figure
that were captured by their cameras.
Nothing else is known that has been made
available to anyone outside a very select few.
Only the original report exists, and all
other copies of it have been destroyed.
The Foundation has undertaken special containment
procedures to make sure that none of the entities
from inside the hotel escape, whether they are
the “evil twins” spawned by humans entering
the building, or the mysterious female being at
the center of the entire disturbing phenomenon.
The Foundation has classified SCP-1919
as Euclid and a two kilometer radius must
be maintained around SCP-1919, with all
roads leading to the building are blocked
or diverted so that no vehicles are able to
reach it. This perimeter is guarded by a set
of at least forty armed and armored guards
at any given time. As it has been determined
that the doubles spawned by 1919 are equipped
with whatever the human they are copying has,
no one is allowed to enter the hotel
with body armor or weapons of any kind.
Anyone that approaches the perimeter that
is not part of an official expedition team
will be immediately terminated. No
new expeditions teams are allowed to
enter the building unless all doubles
from the previous expedition have been
exterminated. In the event that they cannot be
exterminated, enough time must elapse between
expeditions that the previous doubles have starved
to death. Though they do not seem to feel hunger,
the doubles do need to eat to survive, and
will die when left alone for long enough.
SCP-1919 has been sealed off
from the rest of the world,
so that no hapless civilians can wander inside and
find themselves torn to pieces by warped images of
themselves. But that comfort turns cold when you
realize that the SCP Foundation still does not
understand what causes these doubles to spawn. Is
it scientific? Supernatural? Or something else?
No one can be certain. Even more inexplicable
is the entity at the center of all this,
an unknown female presence capable of wreaking
frightening amounts of violence by turning
victims’ own images against them. What is the
purpose of these funhouse mirror nightmares?
Who is she, what is she, and what does she
want? Currently, the doubles have shown no
interest in leaving the hotel except to attack
intruders, and thanks to that fact, as well as
the reinforced perimeter outside, these copycats
have not appeared outside of the building itself.
But what happens if they do escape,
or if the entity that controls them decides
to make her home elsewhere? There is no
telling what could happen if this dark power is
allowed to move beyond its current containment.
Are you prepared to fight a vision of
yourself, twisted almost beyond recognition,
lunging after you with wide bulbous
eyes, unnaturally long arms,
and a distended jaw hanging down below its
neck? Better hope you never have to find out.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Children -
Ouroboros Cycle” and “SCP-055 - Anti Meme”
for more anomalous curiosities
from the SCP Foundation!